i
[Música]
ah
lo casi nunca visto ocurrió ayer en el
parlamento turco islamistas
conservadores nacionalistas
socialdemócratas ultra nacionalistas pro
kurdos liberales y comunistas votaron
todos por la misma resolución que
condena las acciones de israel contra
los palestinos de la franja de gaza y la
zona de cisjordania es algo inaudito en
la política turca que todos los aspectos
de la política estén en una misma en un
mismo lado en nuestro caso por ejemplo
el presidente recep tayip erdogán dijo
ayer que israel es un estado terrorista
por eso mismo durante los últimos días
han habido manifestaciones
multitudinarias en todo el país por toda
turquía con varias decenas de miles de
personas que protestan en contra de
israel díaz a favor de la comunidad
palestina dentro de su propio país en
estas manifestaciones han ocurrido a
pesar de que en turquía pese un
confinamiento y una cuarentena total
desde hace más de 15 días
[Música]
el líbano comparte mucho más que
solidaridad con el pueblo palestino es
el hogar de más de medio millón de
refugiados palestinos que llevan
viviendo por generaciones desde 1948 con
la partición de palestina también para
el líbano israel es su enemigo con el
que ha librado dos guerras en el pasado
y siguen enfrentados al no ponerse de
acuerdo para delimitar sus fronteras
terrestre marítima todo esto hace que
aquí en el líbano se viva con cercanía y
con preocupación los últimos
enfrentamientos en un rally palestina
desde hace dos días ha habido
manifestaciones solidarias y marchas a
favor de los palestinos que están siendo
expulsados del barrio de jerusalén de
seis jarras en los diferentes
campamentos palestinos del país el
presidente michel aún pidió ayer a la
comunidad internacional que intervenga
en palestina porque sin paz no hay
justicia
[Música]
la defensa de la causa palestina y el no
reconocimiento del estado de israel han
sido una de las banderas de la república
islámica desde su creación en 1979 de
hecho el último viernes de ramadán que
en esto que fue el viernes pasado se
celebra el día de qods o la liberación
de jerusalén en la que generalmente
cientos de miles de iraníes salen a la
calle a apoyar a los palestinos esa vez
no fue así por la pandemia solo miles de
personas salieron en carros pero no le
quita importancia al significado que
esto tiene para muchísimos iraníes que
defienden y apoyan a los palestinos esto
ha llevado a que en las últimas horas
las autoridades de la república islámica
se pronuncien desde todos los ángulos el
líder supremo la revolución dijo que los
sionistas sólo entienden el lenguaje de
la fuerza pero fue la guardia
revolucionaria quien hizo el
pronunciamiento más agresivo dijo que
apoyaban este levantamiento a los
palestinos especialmente el movimiento
de la resistencia como se llaman estos
grupos también como hamás y la yihad
islámica que están liderando este ataque
contra israel
[Música]